[Música]
muy sonriente muy seguro de Sí con un
discurso optimista pero que no escapó de
los señalamientos y hostilidades por
parte de su oposición el presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe pronunció su discurso
anual sobre el estado de la unión en el
que hizo un balance de su gestión y
también dio luces del rumbo que puede
tomar su administración para los
próximos dos años para muchos fue un
discurso con pinceladas de populismo en
el que le habló a los trabajadores que
es una importante masa de votantes para
él también criticó al sector empresarial
principalmente a las farmacéuticas
defendió su programa de salud y también
dejó sobre la mesa Aparentemente Y eso
lo vamos a analizar con nuestros
invitados Más adelante se aspira a una
reelección o no también tuvo lugar para
hacer señalamientos contra los
republicanos hablar de economía de China
de Ucrania migración y seguridad por eso
hoy en el debate de France 24 las
reacciones y el después de el discurso
del estado de la unión del presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden para analizar
este tema hemos invitado a Aníbal Romero
él es estratega demócrata y abogado de
inmigración y también está con nosotros
Jeffrey
él es estratega republicano y experto en
marketing político le recuerdo a
nuestros televidentes que también hacen
parte de este debate pueden dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales estamos en Twitter
también en Facebook y en instagram nos
encuentran como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f24 todo junto también le
recuerdo mi cuenta personal arroba
santilogo no olviden también que todos
los contenidos de este programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces saludando a Aníbal
Aníbal Gracias por estar con nosotros
aquí en el programa en el debate y Punto
de partida Como me gusta Llamar a la
primera pregunta aquí en el programa su
opinión general su panorama general de
lo que dejó este discurso del estado de
la unión adelante bienvenido
Muchísimas gracias por la invitación y
efectivamente como usted dice el
presidente estuvo muy seguro de Sí
porque realmente pues la prensa local
aquí en los Estados Unidos está
catalogando como posiblemente uno de los
mejores discursos de los últimos años
aquí en los Estados Unidos creo que
da mucha lástima que lo que terminó
pasando que el partido republicano y
quiero hacer
énfasis que una parte del partido
republicano conocido como los trompistas
que hicieron hacer un circo político de
este evento tan institucional en los
Estados Unidos pero el presidente se
paró muy firme muy
convencido de los logros en los primeros
dos años hubo un momento tan interesante
cuando los republicanos también tuvieron
que pararse y estar de acuerdo de que se
iba a poder negociar el presupuesto de
de la nación sin quitar los programas de
seguro social y Merkel fue un momento
extraordinario donde El Vocero de la
cámara de representantes no sabía ni por
dónde poner la cabeza
Lamentablemente siempre en el partido
republicano vamos a escuchar griterío y
y mire en esto terminó Esta es la imagen
que se van a acordar muchos del discurso
de la nación en esto ha quedado cierto
sector del partido republicano un
populismo que realmente sabemos que no
va a llegar absolutamente a nada los
logros del presidente biden son tengo la
lista y vamos a poder hablarlas
Obviamente el día de hoy vamos a
preguntarle a nuestro siguiente a
Jeffrey también le doy la bienvenida al
programa Gracias por acompañarnos hoy y
en su opinión general del balance que
deja este discurso puntos generales de
Panorama para luego empezar a
profundizar Bienvenido
al presidente Joe biden como lo que es
no este es una persona ya de avanzada
edad y Estaba perdido totalmente perdido
totalmente alejado de la realidad y solo
voy a poner un ejemplo No ya que vamos a
ir al debate en los minutos que que
sigue él dice que la inflación está bajo
control que la que los precios han
bajado la inflación en ese momento en
los Estados Unidos para que sepan la
gente que nos vea alrededor fuera de los
Estados Unidos es de 150 por ciento y
voy a poner como ejemplo solamente un
producto antes de que Joe biden entrara
a la casa blanca la gasolina estaba un
dólar ochenta y cinco centavos yo la
llegué a comprar hasta un dólar 65
centavos el galón en este momento el día
de hoy la gasolina está tres dólares
veintinueve centavos y es un precio
barato aquí en en Washington DC en el
área de Washington dice que estamos
hablando más de 150 por ciento de
inflación un producto básico gasolina
porque bueno que Estados Unidos
todos tienen carro prácticamente otro
producto otro producto dame un segundo
más otro producto los huevos los huevos
la docena de huevos la docena de huevos
en este momento en Estados Unidos está
cinco dólares con cuarenta y nueve
centavos en Walmart Hace dos años lo
podías encontrar hasta en dólar
cincuenta que era lo más caro Ah lo más
caro podrías encontrar una docena de
huevos en un dólar Entonces de qué
inflación
controlada estamos hablando no hay
absolutamente ninguna inflación
controlada en los Estados Unidos el
precio de la gasolina ha aumentado más
de 150 por ciento Qué es lo que está
hablando y en otro en otra etapa
adelante Jeffrey sí adelante Jeffrey
Bueno usted está tocando el tema
económico entonces Comencemos por ese
lado la realidad es que después de la
pandemia Kobe 19 no solamente Estados
Unidos está haciendo frente a una alta
inflación es prácticamente un problema
transversal para casi todas las
economías para la gran mayoría de los
países ese escenario de aumento en los
precios y en los precios de los
combustibles es prácticamente un Común
denominador pero el presidente destacó
esos 12 millones de puestos de trabajo
que ha generado y el buen desempeño que
está empezando a tener la economía su
perspectiva del punto económico ya que
usted mismo lo trajo a la mesa
Estados Unidos es la economía más grande
del mundo
algunos dicen representa el 30% de la
economía otros 50 por ciento Yo creo que
es el 70% de la economía de los del
planeta está representada por la
economía de este país de Estados Unidos
si los precios cambian en los Estados
Unidos o hay una mala política económica
como lo que estamos teniendo en este
momento repercuten todos los países en
toda la órbita Por qué Simplemente
porque las economías alrededor del mundo
están dolarizadas Entonces por qué cómo
generas economía Cómo generas inflación
inmediatamente cortando la producción de
energía
petróleo y gas en los Estados Unidos qué
es lo que hizo
biden al ingresar a la casa blanca Es
por eso que el mismo día que Joe biden
estaba juramentando el precio de la
gasolina aumentó 30 centavos aquí en en
Washington DC entonces No podemos decir
que es transversal que le que que hay
inflación en un que hay que el problema
es global porque la inflación es en
todos los países no alguien la
alguien la ocasiona ahora sobre sobre
los empleos dicen que según el señor
biden hay ha creado doce millones de
empleos eso es mentira también pues no
he leído la estadísticas del del
departamento de trabajo labor department
y se han se han aumentado eh algo de dos
punto tres millones de empleos en los
últimos dos años cosa que es muy bajo
muy bajo y casi no se siente y te digo
por qué no se siente porque han
ingresado ilegalmente por la frontera
Sur la frontera de México alrededor
bueno los que se cuentan Ah cuatro
millones de personas entonces esos dos
punto tres millones de de empleos que
supuestamente se han generado han sido
absorbidos en su mayoría porque son
trabajos de de leyvor por las personas
que han ingresado
ilegalmente por la frontera Sur claro
adelante adelante
su perspectiva del lado económico de lo
que dice Jeffrey sobre sobre esa
creación de empleo y sobre la inflación
yo ya daba el dato Estados Unidos no
escapa a una realidad mundial que es el
aumento de los precios prácticamente
todos los países del Mundo están
encarando la misma situación
Sí yo sí efectivamente Y y miren esto no
tiene nada en contra de Jeffrey yo estoy
seguro que él está muy preparado para
contestar estas preguntas pero claro el
tema es muy difícil para él porque tiene
que defender una causa perdida que es la
causa de los republicanos efectivamente
se han creado 12 millones de trabajos
efectivamente sabemos que la inflación
es mundial O sea no creo que posición en
Francia está acusando a al al señor
macrón de que por culpa de existe
inflación en Francia la economía en
todos los países está sufriendo una
inflación el precio de la gasolina que
era un tema que lo estaban manejando los
republicanos para la campaña bueno Se
tomaron las medidas y la gasolina bajó
el precio de la gasolina va a variar
Dependiendo el estado pero el precio
promedio en los Estados Unidos ha bajado
aparte que en enero de este año hace un
mes se crearon más de 500.000 nuevos
puestos de trabajo la tasa del desempleo
está en 3.4 es la tasa más baja en los
últimos 50 años y eso es lo que va a
determinar qué pasa en las elecciones
del 2024 todo lo demás estos
conversaciones de inflación y todo lo
demás la gente lo que necesita es saber
que la próxima semana va a recibir su
cheque y la gente en los Estados Unidos
está trabajando los indocumentados que
están ingresando a los Estados Unidos
encuentran trabajo de inmediato esa es
la realidad en los Estados Unidos la
economía en los Estados Unidos está
pasando por una etapa está mejorando se
ha firmado una ley entre republicanos y
demócratas un proyecto de ley que se
firmó llamado la ley de infraestructura
que va a crear miles de trabajos para
ampliación de puentes y carreteras en
los Estados Unidos la economía está en
muy buen estado y se está recuperando y
vamos a ver ahora en las elecciones del
2024 como el presidente está listo para
ser reelecto y ya lo vimos en las
elecciones de noviembre como aprobaron
el proyecto del presidente Aníbal
continuó con usted
haciendo un barrido general de lo que
fue el discurso del presidente biden y
como Suele suceder en este tipo de
discursos de la unión se vuelve un gran
listado de logros de la administración
de turno allí en Estados Unidos usted
decía que tenía varios de esos logros o
de varios de esos puntos a destacar de
la administración de el presidente biden
leyendo algunos análisis de medios de
comunicación y analistas en Estados
Unidos dicen que el presidente aprovechó
este segundo discurso para poner sobre
la mesa todos estos logros de su
administración porque sabe que el
panorama de El Congreso no le favorece
para los dos años que viene y no va a
ser tan fácil llevar a cabo las reformas
que él considera desde su administración
que deben ser realizadas Cuál es su
análisis nombre algunas de esos puntos
de esos puntos importantes destacados
del presidente y ya le preguntó a
Jeffrey por esa perspectiva que piensa
Sí definitivamente lo que usted dice es
100% correcto estoy mil por ciento de
acuerdo con usted era el momento
político para el presidente biden
demostrar que en los últimos dos años ha
podido firmar
300 leyes bipartidistas no porque eso es
algo muy importante que el presidente
Como tiene tanto tiempo en el congreso
tiene la habilidad para poder firmar
leyes conjuntamente con el partido
republicano vemos el plan de
infraestructura que ya lo mencioné que
vamos a poder crear se va a poder crear
miles de plazas de trabajo en los
Estados Unidos
eso en los últimos dos años obviamente
en este momento el problema que tiene el
presidente biden es que ya no tiene
control de la cámara de representantes y
la cámara de representantes es manejada
por republicano pero los republicanos
también están divididos el presidente
biden si pudiera llegar a acuerdos con
republicanos como lo hizo ayer en
televisión nacional separaron
republicanos y prometieron en cámaras
que no iban a eliminar ciertos gastos
perdón y no iban a cortar ciertos gastos
del seguro social inverter y el líder
del partido republicano tiene un serio
problema porque hay un grupo de
republicanos que yo siempre les digo los
trompistas que no van a dejar aprobar
ningún tipo de ley y ahí viene el
problema fundamental entonces lo que
vemos para los próximos dos años es una
campaña política para la reelección eso
es lo que vamos a ver con los logros que
ya se ha llegado va a ser muy difícil
que se pueda aprobar una ley con los
trompistas en el congreso de la cámara
de representantes y va a haber muchísima
negociación entre las partes Jeffrey
Cuál es su perspectiva sobre este punto
adelante
solamente para contestar bien rapidito
sobre la el incremento de la gasolina ha
bajado 20 centavos pero ya ha subido un
dólar 70 ya lo he dicho pues no subió de
uno sesenta y cinco uno noventa y ahora
está tres veinte estuvo tres cincuenta
ha bajado 20 centavos o sea Es como ir a
la tienda y te dicen esto está en oferta
debajo veinte centavos pero ya te subí
tres tres o cuatro dólares el segundo
punto el segundo punto aquel señor dice
de que todos los inmigrantes ilegales
los que cruzan en la frontera vienen
encuentran trabajo en los Estados Unidos
inmediatamente por favor eso está
incentivando la inmigración ilegal y eso
es mentira también eso es mentira y si
en caso fuera verdad le quitan el
trabajo a un ciudadano de los Estados
Unidos O a un inmigrante que ya está acá
veinte o treinta años y no ha podido
solucionar su problema migratorio O sea
que no tiene documentos muy malo lo que
está diciendo ahora lo que el ahora lo
que dice lo que mencionan de que con
inversión pública se va a solucionar el
problema de la inflación eso es una
falacia eso es mentir ese es un programa
de keyness ya se ha hecho en los Estados
Unidos durante el gobierno de Obama de
incentivar el trabajo la producción de
trabajo la creación de trabajo con
con inversión pública y te digo por qué
Porque la inversión pública se financia
con los impuestos de los ciudadanos Qué
significa esto te meten la mano bolsillo
te sacan la plata y luego la vuelven a
poner en la economía haciendo obra
pública no funciona es un es es es la
teoría de keynes no funciona para
incentivar la la economía Tienes que
liberalizar darle oportunidad a la gente
que trabaje y sobre todo bajando los
impuestos ahora sobre las leyes de que
tienen que ponerse de acuerdo
republicanos y demócratas bueno Por
supuesto que tienen que ponerse de
acuerdo
es una democracia pero no se puede
comprometer
ningún partido a promulgar leyes que no
tienen sentido leyes leyes tontas por
ejemplo esta ley de infraestructura
es una tontería totalmente una tontería
porque es inversión pública nuevamente
lo repito que es la inversión pública la
inversión pública se hace con el dinero
del contribuyente les mete la mano al
bolsillo al contribuyente Mediante los
impuestos y la ponen en infraestructura
que muchas veces no sirve Ah no sirve yo
no estoy de acuerdo con la inversión
pública la inversión el estatal en
infraestructura porque es cara y al
final no sirve para los fines que ese
proyecto Jeffrey en ese en ese sentido
rápidamente le pido que sea muy puntual
entonces Estados Unidos no debería
invertir en esta renovación de
infraestructura de las autopistas los
puertos mejorar el sistema de trenes
para hacer competencia a nivel
internacional por ejemplo a la Unión
Europea o por ejemplo a China que
desarrolló en menos de una década un
sistema de
sistema ferroviario sumamente eficiente
que conecta los principales puertos del
país ahorrando muchísimos costos esto no
le resta competitividad a Estados Unidos
y ya seguimos analizando los puntos del
debate solamente sistema ferroviario el
sistema ferroviario en Europa es
deficiente y no produce ganancias
solamente se mantiene con el con el
subsidio del Estado Es falso que el
sistema ferroviario abarata Los costos
completamente completamente falso ahora
tu pregunta es muy amplia tú me dices
que que es malo que que se invierta en
en puertos en aeropuertos en autopistas
o en esto y el otro hay que tomarlo
Punto por punto qué mi pregunta no es
esa Mi pregunta es si no se le resta
competitividad a Estados Unidos sino se
actualiza la infraestructura
Jeffrey te perdí te perdiste perdí mi
pregunta es si al no actualizar la
infraestructura de Estados Unidos no se
resta competitividad Pero qué
infraestructura Ese es mi mi pregunta
qué tipo de infraestructura tú me dices
de trenes bueno los trenes en Europa
como tú pones el ejemplo o en China en
otro caso como tú pones el ejemplo son
más caros que lo que producen Y a qué
otro qué qué otro tipo de
infraestructura me estás diciendo
autopistas Sí en general la
infraestructura para que sea un país
Unido que usted pueda mover una carga de
una Costa a otra para poderlo exportar
para diferentes puntos del planeta no es
tan difícil de entender
la única la única inversión de
infraestructura que Estados Unidos
necesita en este momento es en energía
pero no te estoy no me estoy refiriendo
a la energía solar energía eólica que es
carísima y e ineficiente lo que
necesitamos acá es inversión en
infraestructura es
es energía barata que nuevamente se
vuelvan a dar licencias para explotar
los
pozos petroleros el
gas en Quito el aceite de en Quito que
se den más permisos para la energía
nuclear y que se abran y que se abran
las centrales de Carbón que son baratas
son baratas y no contaminan tanto como
decían antes tú mencionas china pues
China tiene energía nuclear China tiene
energía a base de Carbón lo está
haciendo también en este momento
Alemania porque tiene una déficit de
energía por motivos de la guerra claro
la pregunta sobre infraestructura tiene
que ser específica le pido que cerremos
el paréntesis para no desviarnos del
tema central que es el el discurso y le
pregunto por el tono del discurso lo
decía yo en la introducción del programa
hay quienes han dicho que el discurso
del presidente biden tuvo
tonos o pinceladas de ser muy populista
que le habló a los trabajadores que es
una parte de la masa de la de la
sociedad estadounidense muy importante
para él sobre todo si va a aspirar a una
reelección Y criticó de frente al sector
empresarial Como por ejemplo las
farmacéuticas que son muy importantes
para la economía de Estados Unidos o
análisis sobre ese tema por favor
la crítica que ha hecho bueno el
discurso de de fue bien populista
Se ha basado prácticamente en Elevar los
impuestos con el pie con la con la con
la vieja falacia de que los ricos no
pagan no pagan su la parte que debían
pagar que los pobres paga menos o que la
clase media paga menos o que la
industria farmacéutica no está
cumpliendo
con pagar lo que debería con lo que
debería pagar totalmente totalmente
populista la economía o cualquier
economía no mejora cobrando los
impuestos no mejora metiéndole la mano
al contribuyente no mejora no mejora
yendo contra la productividad del de una
empresa biden dijo de que iba a
promulgar una ley por la cual las
empresas o las corporaciones pagar 15%
de impuesto a la renta porque
supuestamente en los Estados Unidos
pagan cero Cómo vas a incentivar el
empleo Cómo vas a incentivar el empleo
si le estás diciendo a las empresas que
al final son individuos asociados para
producir qué les vas a subir los
impuestos dónde se van el dónde se van a
ir las empresas se van a ir a un país
donde no les cobren la cantidad de
impuestos que le cobran aquí en los
Estados Unidos por si acaso Ah china no
tiene impuesto a la renta china no te
cobran impuesto a la renta Entonces cómo
lo vas a cómo lo vas a hacer es una
contradicción en sí mismo
su opinión sobre este tema adelante
voy a defender a Jeffrey porque es muy
difícil para él
que el discurso sea
anti cuando en realidad lo que hemos
visto en los Estados Unidos en los
últimos dos años no lo habíamos visto en
algún tiempo nuevamente quiero hacer
hincapié en el tres punto cuatro de la
tasa del desempleo quiero hacer hincapié
de que el presidente biden ya está rumbo
a la reelección efectivamente Yo también
podría decir que fue un discurso
populista porque él sabe que tiene que
ganar en lugares como Wisconsin Mexican
pensolonia que son los estados donde
realmente se va a determinar Quién es el
próximo presidente el partido
republicano no tiene candidato no sé si
han estado viendo ustedes las noticias
últimamente que el candidato presidente
ex presidente Trump está acusando al
candidato Randy Sánchez de ser pedófilo
y hoy día ha tenido que contestar el
candidato de santes decir que no es
correcto estar atacándose entre sí no
hay un discurso del partido republicano
no tienen un discurso para el 2024
de Perder tres elecciones seguidas con
el discurso populista del presidente
Trump el plan de infraestructura que
está criticando Jeffrey fue aprobado por
el partido republicano
consiguió los votos republicanos y es el
futuro de los Estados Unidos por lo
tanto ayer nos dimos cuenta que
efectivamente el presidente biden va la
reelección tanto que se ve de que él no
está bien Dios mío va a cumplir 80 años
se paró firme hizo quedar mal a la a la
a la a la a la barra brava eh trompista
que lo único que hacían era gritar y los
comprometió a no cortar el seguro social
Imagínese en época de elecciones ciertos
republicanos están amenazando como el
gobernador con el senador de la Florida
en cortar el seguro social o sea
realmente yo creo que el partido
republicano tiene que prepararse para
las elecciones del 2021 vamos a ver si
pueden conseguir un candidato de centro
porque la verdad es que veinticuatro lo
veo muy difícil Aníbal y esas críticas
que hizo al sector farmacéutico
recordemos que las farmacéuticas
estadounidenses fueron sumamente
importantes en esa Alianza con el
gobierno para poder hacer frente a la
pandemia del Coby 19 dar una respuesta
rápida a nivel internacional con la
producción de las de las vacunas
tuvieron ganancias millonarias
históricas y han generado también empleo
qué se puede decir de estas críticas
Porque estos señalamientos al sector
farmacéutico y al empresariado en
general
Yo creo que es legítimo o sea gracias a
Dios Yo tengo un buen seguro médico yo
no pago nada pero la persona que gana
menos de 50 mil dólares en el país que
es diabético tiene que pagar una
insulina carísima no estamos hablando de
los más pobres que tienen mercade pero
estamos hablando de la clase media los
independientes que van a votar del
precio de la medicina en Estados Unidos
es un escándalo es un gracias a Dios Yo
también tengo raíces de América Latina y
si tuviera un problema me fuera América
Latina a comprar medicina Porque aquí es
imposible comprar para una persona que
no puede pagar un seguro médico y que la
medicina es demasiada cara eso es lo que
él va a seguir diciendo porque es verdad
la farmacéuticas hacen tanto dinero y
obviamente es un sector importante pero
las ganancias ponen a un gran sector de
la población los que ganan entre tal vez
40 y 60 mil dólares sin poder cubrir los
gastos básicos que necesitan no los más
pobres que tienen Mary Kate no como yo
que tenga un seguro que puedo conseguir
lo que me da la gana y no voy a pagar un
centavo pero la clase media que son las
que van a votar Mexican
ahí se deciden las elecciones nuevamente
sí pasemos a un tema importante el
presidente también tocó algunos puntos
destacados del tema migratorio es un es
problemático lo que sucede en la
frontera con México
ha sido siempre un tema complicado para
las diferentes administraciones
hablo de una reforma migratoria
absolutamente necesaria O al menos una
vía para poder obtener la ciudadanía
Jeffrey muy puntual por favor su
perspectiva sobre ese tema
desde el primer día en que entró el
señor biden a la casa blanca comenzaron
a organizar las caravanas por las
famosas caravanas de migrantes que han
venido de todo bueno algunas nacen en en
Honduras y van recogiendo gente pues no
y solamente no solamente hay
hispanoamericanos en esas caravanas Pues
hay gente de medio oeste hay rusos hay
ucranianos pero cuándo ha empezado este
este problema de la inmigración
completamente descontrolada con o
durante el gobierno de Joe biden sea
solucionado el problema no no se ha
solucionado el problema es más el
problema se agrava con los días se
nombró como
zar de inmigración a la vicepresidenta
camala Harris y que yo sepa ha ido a
visitar la la frontera de Sur no nunca
ha ido fui a visitar algunos países de
Centroamérica
a tomarse la foto pero no ha solucionado
absolutamente nada pero el problema de
fondo aquí con las frontera sur son las
mafias de inmigración las los carteles
que cobran un cupo a cada persona que
cruza la frontera se dice de que ahorita
el costo está entre 25.000 y 60 mil
dólares por persona que los coyotes y
las mafias que controlan la frontera El
el gobierno de México no controla la
frontera no tiene poder
cobran para que cada inmigrante cruce la
frontera y cruce el cruce ilegalmente
junto con ellos vienen el tráfico de
mujeres tienen el tráfico de niños que
muchos terminan en prostitución están
ingresando una cantidad terrible inmensa
de droga fenta
opio que está ocasionando una crisis de
fentanilo en los Estados Unidos con
miles de miles de Muertos es justamente
Jeffrey
justamente
el presidente vaiden habló de la crisis
y de lo importante que es empezar a
luchar o fortalecer los planes para
poder combatir este problema que se ha
convertido en Estados Unidos por el
consumo de fentanilo la perspectiva
sobre este tema Aníbal el tema
migratorio también Bueno ya que han
tocado el tema del fentanilo que lo
mencionó el presidente como yo lo decía
su opinión
Muchas gracias
Ese es mi tema tengo 20 años trabajando
en el en el en el tema migratorio muy
frustrado de que no hay una solución
Pero insisto tengo 20 años con el mismo
cuento Esto no es el presidente Buy ni
del presidente Trump ni el presidente
Obama ni Bush uno Bush dos este es la
realidad de los Estados Unidos la
realidad de los Estados Unidos es que
los inmigrantes vienen a los Estados
Unidos y a trabajar y es verdad hay que
controlar la frontera pero los
republicanos no ofrecen nada Lo único
que quieren es oponerse a cualquier tipo
de programa ya existió una propuesta en
el 2012 que marco Rubio también firmó y
la cámara de representantes decidió en
ese momento
el señor beiner que era El Vocero de la
cámara decidió que no quería votar por
ese tema entonces que efectivamente Hay
un problema siempre ha habido un
problema que las caravanas existen
siempre hay caravanas eso ya no ha
cambiado lo hemos visto es un obviamente
un un una una estrategia política del
partido republicano en época de elección
que no ha funcionado tú prendes un canal
de televisión que ni siquiera los voy a
mencionar y lo único que hablan es de
caravanas Pero eso no es nada nuevo
entonces de que hay un problema en la
frontera obviamente hay una frontera Hay
un problema en la frontera que el
presidente ha pedido que se pongan de
acuerdo republicanos y demócratas y
busquen una solución si lo está haciendo
pero los republicanos en la cámara baja
no lo van a hacer el senado está
dispuesto a trabajar hay senadores que
están dispuestos a trabajar para esto
pero los republicanos en la cámara red
de baja no lo quieren hacer porque con
eso mueven un grupo
antimigrante que son los que van a votar
en las primarias republicanas Así que no
va a haber ningún tipo de solución aquí
y el presidente va a ir solamente tiene
que actuar por acción ejecutiva que ahí
sí lo critican creo que hay muchas cosas
que pueden hacer Ojalá que lo haga el
presidente va a ir por acción ejecutiva
Aníbal Jeffrey justamente cito al
presidente biden en su discurso dijo los
problemas de la frontera de Estados
Unidos y México no se van a solucionar
Hasta que el congreso
tome una decisión y actúe son palabras
textuales del presidente lo ha dicho
Ayer ya me quedan pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa
se nos quedan por fuera por supuesto
temas como el tema Internacional de la
relación con Ucrania con china el tema
de las armas también pero quiero
preguntarles qué faltó en este discurso
por parte del presidente Qué temas se le
quedó por fuera o qué tema estaban
esperando ustedes que el presidente
tocara mencionar a elaborar y y
desmenuzara en su discurso que no habló
que no lo mencionó comienzo la ronda la
inversa entonces comienzo con Aníbal y
nos preparamos para las conclusiones
Aníbal adelante
bueno soy
voté por el presidente biden volveré a
votar por el presidente biden pero si
hay que criticarlo hay que criticarlo y
creo que con el nuevo paquete con el
nuevo plan de infraestructura van a
existir Muchos trabajos aquí en los
Estados Unidos entonces me hubiera
encantado escucharlo ser mucho más
frontal con el tema migratorio con que
podemos hacer para ver cómo podemos
legalizar a las personas que están aquí
que no tienen permisos de trabajo y que
existe un sector informal que son
explotados no lo escuché hablar mucho de
eso me gustaría que sea mucho más fuerte
en inmigración que lo prometió y vamos a
estar pendientes de eso y ya justamente
Yo decía la Francia y la frase del
presidente prácticamente le le descarga
la responsabilidad al congreso se la
vaya un poco las manos Jeffrey su
opinión
la fronteras de los Estados Unidos están
a cargo del Gobierno Federal bastaría
con que el presidente biden de una orden
una orden ejecutiva y ya digan bueno
puede trasladar cierta cantidad de
tropas en la frontera para sellarla
suficiente ahora el tema legislativo es
aparte pues no si es que se tiene que
buscar alguna solución para los
inmigrantes que están ya en los Estados
Unidos por 20-30 años que la mayoría son
hispanos y ahora son republicanos porque
están viendo que los nuevos las personas
nuevas que llegan los Estados Unidos les
han les están quitando su su trabajo por
eso lo que se está viendo se está se
reflejan las elecciones que los hispanos
los hispanos que votan están votando más
por el partido republicano porque los
demócratas están trayendo mal más
inmigrantes que dañan sus escuelas dañan
los servicios que reciben y dañan sus
puestos de trabajo ahora la pregunta
específica que tú haces tiene un par de
minutos por favor Le pido que no se
extienda mucho Necesito hacer las
conclusiones y usted se me prolonga
demasiado y me hace mucho contexto y y y
y y y evita responder la pregunta
entonces empiezo las conclusiones por
usted qué sigue entonces para estos dos
años del presidente y se postula o no
para la reelección rápidamente porque me
quedan pocos segundos
No te entendí la pregunta repitela por
favor la conclusión que siguen entonces
para estos dos años del presidente hay
reelección
el partido demócrata ya le bajado del
dedo a Joe biden es un candidato flojo
es un candidato débil para el 2024 ya lo
que ha sucedido ahora ahora poco que
hubo
un allanamiento en una de sus oficinas y
se encontraba documentos supuestamente
clasificados el partido de boca ya ha
bajado los dedos ya le ha bajado el dedo
a biden ahora qué se espera por estos
dos años espero espero que el presidente
Joe biden se comprometa a terminar con
la guerra en en Ucrania porque está
llevando al mundo entero a una
conflagración nuclear y este señor no
sabe lo que está haciendo No sabe lo que
dice no sabe lo que piensa Jeffrey
justamente cuando ayer dijo no hay
ningún presidente lo tengo que cortar me
queda un minuto y y nuestro siguiente
invitado tiene también que hacer la
conclusión es lo que corresponde los dos
tienen derecho a hacerla a nivel su
conclusión para el cierre por favor
el presidente biden es el presidente de
los Estados Unidos es el candidato a la
presidencia por ser el encoment es decir
la persona que está en el lugar
de la presidencia
yo veo la economía mejorando la gente
está trabajando está así recibiendo su
discurso está haciendo lo que tiene que
hacer un Ucrania que por cierto Acabo de
ver que también está en Francia Yo creo
que el mundo entero está con celinski Y
entonces creo que vamos en buen camino
el presidente está bien para la
reelección Aníbal Jeffrey Muchas gracias
por haber estado con nosotros haber
hecho este análisis para la audiencia de
France 24 es todo por hoy En nombre del
equipo Les agradecemos la sintonía la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Giovanni agudelo y la producción de
invitados a cargo de Tania Herrera siga
con France 24
[Música]